How do I know if I'm eliminating my toxins, okay?
I'm starting doing chelation, I'm doing detox.
How do I know I got rid of all my toxins?
That is a good question.
So first of all, theoretically, we go,
okay, I have mercury toxicity.
So I do a mercury detox, and my mercury toxicity is gone.
And I got rid of all my mercury.
That's theoretical dreaming.
You're never going to get rid of all your toxins number one.
Well, I understand that, but how I know
that I get rid, get my toxic load down
that it is less of a problem.
The only way to know that is to do some testing.
So can easyology testing will help us understand that.
So if you come back and I test you again,
I can test you where we're at with that toxic load.
There's other toxic load testing that can be done too.
So we could look at stool sample testing.
There's herodalysis testing that I'm not a big fan of.
There's urinary testing that I'm not,
that's much more accurate, but I'm not a fan of
because you have to overload on a chelator in order
to measure the urine spill, the spill of the heavy metal
in the urine.
So the safest is can easyology testing by opinion.
But the truth is you have to realize that
you are always toxifying yourself.
So even if, okay, I cleaned up my diet,
I'm not eating any pesticides because I mean,
all organic food now.
Well, first of all, does organic food have pesticides in it?
Well, no, they're not sprayed pesticides
that way, organic food.
Well, that's true, but there's crossover.
So I'll guarantee if we did a chelatoralysis
of all of our organic food in the grocery store,
we would find some pesticides.
So there is some in, even when we're trying to do everything
positively right, we're still gonna be exposed
to food-borne chemicals.
Secondly, we're exposed to toxins everywhere.
We breathe them in.
So the fastest way to get a poison in somebody's body
is to inject it into their bloodstream.
The second fastest way to get a poison in someone's body
is to breathe it in.
So when I breathe in a toxin like exhaust,
I breathe in that in.
That is crossing over my alveolar spaces
and my lungs going right directly into my bloodstream.
It doesn't go through digestion like something
and my food does.
It goes right into my bloodstream.
So that is a huge source of toxicity
that is really hard to get around.
You're good to be exposed to it.
So it is leeching from your carpeting.
It is leeching from your sheet rock.
It is leeching from, it's just everywhere, okay?
We're not talking about pesticides.
You're talking about intergalic compounds.
So we're all exposed to toxins
and it is as long as we are toxifying ourselves
at a greater rate than our body's ability
to rid ourselves of those toxins.
We are becoming more toxic.
So do we ever stop detoxing?
In a sense, we might take a break from using a support
of that pathway.
We might take a break from using milk thistle
for a couple of days or something like that.
But in reality, your body is never stopping detoxing.
So you're always detoxing or you're going to die.
So that's a constant process.
But how do you know you're winning the battle
or you're losing the battle
is the only way to do it is to test.
You can say, well, I feel better.
I'm not as bloated.
My liver doesn't hurt anymore.
Different things like that can give you hints to that.
But the only perfect way to know
is to go back to the test that found in the first place.
So to do that is a wise thing sometimes.
So hopefully that answers that question.
Okay.